foreign
I would like to begin
by expressing my sadness for the latest
disaster of the Greek coast and the
unnecessary loss of human life that we
see all too often in the Mediterranean
Sea this is an unsustainable situation
that is unacceptable
and it is an absolute priority for the
European Union to prevent these deaths
and alongside its Mediterranean partners
let me first turn to the issue of search
and rescue saving lives is not optional
we have a duty to help vessels and
people who are in distress at Sea
um to do this in the coordination
incentive for maritime rescue and this
is governed by International instruments
on maritime law and Frontline bodies are
working on a daily basis to implement
these instruments however
although the surgeon rescue
um
isn't for under EU competence with the
European Union must play a key role our
front line for action should always be
the prevention of the perilous Journeys
across the Mediterranean Sea the more
people who do not begin this uh perilous
Journey the fewer lives will be lost
and it's with this objective and in line
of with our general objective for
migration that I wish to stress the
council's commitment to the fight
against trafficking goings and Smugglers
and to uh and its intention to dismantle
that the business model these people are
using the lives of migrants in order to
obtain
um
profit now
let me turn to the work that we have
been doing together with third countries
both countries of origin and Transit
countries in line with the action lines
set out in the extraordinary Council of
uh February initiatives have been
launched at the highest possible level
with major Partners such as Bangladesh
Iraq Pakistan and Tunisia and we provide
support and we also cooperate with many
partners in the Mediterranean to improve
capacity and management of borders and
Asylum especially when it comes to
search and rescue operations and this
work will continue and will be
intensified as and when it is possible I
have so far focused on the operational
aspects of migration but let me also
mention
just how much progress has been made
when it comes to the migration and
Asylum pact which will improve the
efficiency of our procedures at Europe's
external borders I can assure you that
the the Spanish presidency will work uh
pick up the work of previous
presidencies which I am grateful for to
ensure that Council together with
Parliament can reach an agreement on
these very important legislative
proposals
amongst them the regulation on crisis
situations
alongside the pact we will continue our
commitment to building up the EU rules
on return and establishing safe and
legal routes to the European Union
finally
allowed me to mention the reactivation
of the group contact group on search and
rescue of the European commission which
is seeking new forms of cooperation in
the field particularly when it comes to
the exchange of information amongst
member states and improving the mapping
of the search and rescue situations in
the Mediterranean honorable members let
me conclude by saying that the European
Union needs a overarching holistic
migration policy that it can support
those who need support and avoid
migrants losing their lives we have a
number of lines of action for this work
and
bringing all of these actions together
will yield the results that we all
desire thank you for your attention
thank you Minister Navarro Rios and now
on behalf of the commission commissioner
Johansson
thank you president
honorable members Secretary of State
Navarro Rios
the Adriana sank on 14th of June
the loss as many as 600 Souls
making this one the worst shipwreck not
just in the Mediterranean
not just of Migrant vessels
but one of the worst shipwrecks this
Century worldwide
we must honor the Dead
help the survivors
establish the facts
what appears to have happened the
Smugglers brought their victims to the
troller that was to be their tomb
pack them like sardines like cattle like
cargo
possibly 750 people
women and children down below
the boat drifting rocking we can imagine
the Panic spreading
in the dead of the night the Adriana
suddenly turned over and sank
four kilometers down into the abyss
dragging all within down with her
none of the women and children survived
I immediately contacted from Texas
executive director Hans laytons I also
spoke with the Greek caretaker
government and the head of the Hellenic
Coast Guard
and with the newly appointed Greek
ministers last week our agencies
intervened also immediately frontex by
air identified the vessel at the scene
the frontex exactly director was on the
ground in Greece the next day to support
frontex also launched a serious incident
report the EU Asylum agency helped
survivors in malacasa
just over 100 people were saved from the
sea after the Adriana capsized
there are many unanswered questions here
now we need to establish exactly what
happened
every step of this fatal Journey
why the Adriana sank
the Greek General prosecutor launched an
investigation
the prosecutor investigated smuggling
and the naval Court the Greek Coast
Guard's response
these investigations need to bring trust
and confidence that the facts can be
established including the smuggling
route followed
we know that the practice of irregular
departures from Eastern Libya have
increased by 600 percent this year
Libya remains
a very complicated situation as again
shown recently
and let me make clear coast guards have
to carry out the responsibilities in
full respect of international law
this means any demonstrations of
violence is unacceptable
let us remember our fundamental
principle
our first duty is to save lives
this is what coast guards in countries
of first entry are doing on a daily
basis
the EU does everything in its power to
support member states on search and
rescue this year alone frontex helped to
save Twenty Thousand Lives
the commission relaunched the search and
rescue contract group and pushes member
states to make progress working towards
a common framework on search and rescue
and in The Pact we have proposed special
solidarity measures for search and
rescue
any serious attempt to saving lives has
to be also include developing legal
Pathways and information campaigns along
irregular routes to alert people of
deadly dangers
we are supporting such campaigns in
Morocco Indonesia in Niger in Senegal in
Mauritania in The Gambia
but we also need to fight the Smugglers
the Smugglers Who Sold people tickets
not to Europe but to their deaths
last week europol announced that
dismantling by Spain of a smuggling gang
which spanned nine countries
we have set up by operational and this
Magnus Partnerships with Niger with
Morocco with Tunisia
I welcome Pakistani prime minister
sharif's order to crack down the
Smugglers right after the disaster
and we are working with Senegal on the
Atlantic route
a route that again this week revealed
how deadly it is
last month we proposed a toolbox to
address misuse of commercial transport
for irregular migration
we must change smuggling from a low risk
High profit crime into a high risk low
profit crime and we need EU laws fit for
purpose
I've already issued guidance on
non-criminalization or Genuine
humanitarian assistance and now the
commission is also assessing the
facilitators package which is over 20
years old
last Tuesday I was in lampedusa with the
Italian Minister piante Dorsey
4 000 people had arrived over the
weekend the majority immediately
transferred only 500 were left
the facilities were dignified and
respectful
I met a young man from Chad a young
woman from Ivory Coast
they were so follow and full of energy
of plans and ambition they were already
learning Italian
our economies need young people like
these
they told me they had walked two months
through the desert before paying the
Smugglers taking the boat from Tunisia
it's not the way to come to Europe
we need to continue to work on legal
pathways we will Implement Talent
partnership for labor migration and in
October I will propose an EU talent pool
to match Talent with employers
I have also asked member states to
pledge generously on the resettlement
for refugees
only with the comprehensive approach
preventing irregular departures fighting
Smugglers improving legal Pathways
working in close partnership with
countries of origin and Transit can we
manage migration safely and effectively
and of course we need then an agreement
on The Pact we are making good progress
and I welcome the message from the
Spanish um minister of State on the good
progress that the Spanish presidency is
now doing I call on you all to seize the
opportunity to reach an agreement within
this mandate
above the Adriana
the water are now silent
no no tombstone
no marker
nothing to remember the names
let our action be our Monument
thank you
thank you very much Madam commissioner
now on behalf of the group of the
European People's Party colleague Mr
Mandel before resume
thank you madam president Madam
commissioner dear colleagues
right now we're dealing with a prodigy
tragedy of an enormous
circumference
it's almost every day there are new
deaths in the Mediterranean we have to
see what are the causes of this the
causes are on a chain of tragedies and
this chain begins with disinformation
so that people in the countries of
origin receive
false information as to how they could
travel to Europe and then what they
could expect in the EU we're spread who
is spreading this disinformation it's
organized crime organized crime who do
Smugglers
and this is one of the worst form of
organized crime of our times and we also
know that there are State actors
throughout the world involved and and
they do this to put pressure on the
European Union
and those who suffer are those who
travel
they invest their money in these uh
Smugglers they take a dangerous path and
many
die and that is the tragedy those who
survive
we end up on the external borders of the
EU and then they have a missile Asylum
application and you know ladies and
gentlemen that more than 80 percent Who
start that Asylum
um procedure don't enjoy the right to
Asylum so they they lose time those who
don't lose their lives sometimes years
they lose years of their lives and
that's why I think we have to fight
disinformation
that's why we have to have Asylum
procedures sped up while we have to
strengthen the protection at external
borders and we have to make it clear to
the peop in the countries of origin we
have to explain to people what other
genuine uh opportunities in Europe and
how dangerous the travel is we have to
have a broad approach to fighting
organized crime they they endanger human
lives
and I think this is all taken into
account in this resolution thank you
thank you very much on behalf of the
group of the progressive Alliance of
socialists and Democrats in the European
Parliament colleague
thank you
for years now we've been discussing a
European migration and Asylum policy and
the many aspects linked to this
yet today in our debate we're discussing
just one thing
saving humans from drowning and it's not
a political decision it's a humanitarian
and legal obligation I don't know how
many times we and others in this house
have been discussing these issues and
how many times more we will have to
rerun this discussion we will not give
up until the council the member states
and the commission
can
finally at long last take the
Urgent approach that this challenge
really deserves the challenge and task
is not all that complicated ensure that
we can have coordinated European
Maritime rescue missions with support
from frontex they take marinostrum as
inspiration for this
yet sadly the thought that we have to
save human rights has not made it into
the conclusions of the council
again and again we keep hearing reports
of how
member states have been turning a blind
eye have been withholding support
denying support and when Civil Society
has been criminalized or prevented from
trying to save lives
stunned up and to your
humanitarian obligations and
responsibilities this would be a very
sound basis for further discussion thank
you very much on behalf of renew Europe
group colleague Madame Keller
foreign
rescue at Sea is first and foremost a
humanitarian Duty
it's not a variation for certain numbers
of thousands of migrants our colleagues
on the extreme right can't decide in the
fate of families and children using
their disgusting soul and slogans and
um Wars at Sea are not a solution to
migratory Management in the face of
distress at Sea our common values our
European history calls for a single line
of conduct as you yourself recalled
Madam commissioner and that is to save
human lives there should be no debate on
this but 25 000 people have died or have
disappeared since 2014 in the
Mediterranean the tragic shipwreck of a
a migrant boat carrying 750 people off
the Greek coasts in the middle of June
shocked all of us with my group renew
Europe or my colleagues I also call for
the creation of a European to search and
rescue mission together with member
states and with frontex cooperating with
all the players involved this Mission as
you yourself said once again Madam
commissioner must go hand in hand with a
determined
struggle against the Smugglers and human
traffickers let's stop this disgusting
traffic at source including in third
countries let's take stringent measures
to dismantle these criminal networks
colleagues it is urgent that we act
thank you
best seen on behalf of the group of the
greens European free Alliance colleague
Mr Marquardt floresios
um
I don't know how others feel about this
but I find it very difficult to have to
have these debates again and again and I
draft a speech and knowing full well
that uh this kind of thing will happen
again and the situation will not improve
I find it very very difficult to have to
say yes people must be saved lives must
be saved ngos shouldn't be criminalized
we must investigate disasters and we
have the
um disaster in pillows and there's not a
common effort to rescue people there's
no common effort to even deal with the
bodies that have been recovered from the
Shipwreck well what happened
an overcrowded vessel there was the
whole thing was very dangerous there was
a clear indication of distress
um frontex was informed uh Greece was
informed and Greece didn't organize a
rescue mission Grace didn't send rescue
vessels and didn't even ask a frontex to
watch The Vessel because there was no
wish for the vessel to be watched why we
heard this 13 hours after of waiting we
sent special
units to try and tow the vessel into
Italian Waters and one The Vessel was
being towed The Vessel capsized it
started sinking and when I started
sinking there wasn't an immediate effort
to actually save lives it took a long
time for that to begin and for some
survivors to be taken and these
survivors were taken to closed
facilities no contact with
um journalists their phones were being
confiscated so that all evidence could
be taken away and this is not a disaster
it's not an accent it's a criminal act
and we need to clear up the
circumstances around this act
human lives may be dignity dignified but
if that is a clear yes to that human
dignity then we need to show what human
dignity in fact means in Europe we
should show that we can act we should
show and the European commission must
contribute to ensure that they can
support search and rescue organizations
if indeed such and rescue is as
important as people people keep on
saying it is very much on behalf of the
European conservatives and reformers
group Mrs Cancun de floresios
foreign
minister
unfortunately people will continue to
die trying to reach Europe
and that's because that's how our Asylum
system works right now
reaching the European Mainland is the
necessary condition to obtain Asylum and
that's where the mistake lies every dead
person in the Mediterranean is a victim
of this system
when are we going to realize this
doesn't work
citizens have said that for a while and
now they want
decisive action
and I think we have to say that plainly
but that's the problem anyone who has a
different opinion about Asylum or
migration is demonized even canceled
there are all kinds of taboos especially
from the left wing and at the same time
extreme parties continue to grow and
they reap what Europe sows what shocks
me is that we have the power to do so
much but we don't dare what we should do
is however quite obvious we have to stop
spreading stop rewarding these
life-threatening trips you can't
give them the prospect of the right of
residents I think we'd have a more
Humane system if we were braver for the
identity and democracy group
Gracia president
thank you president commissioner just
three weeks ago I was in lampedusa on a
mission with the Libre committee and all
the colleagues there talked about the
work self-sacrifice of a population that
over these years has given assistance in
Hospitality offering those who have
arrived the best face of Europe as uh at
our recent meeting the mayor Mr manino
recalled but talk counts for a little
it's very easy to sit here and talk for
those who are not in the front line and
for those who like the ngos are very
happy to work with reports of others and
to show hospitality and work together
with those who determine deaths at Sea
we'll never get tired of saying it the
only solution is to act on the external
Dimension strengthening cooperation with
third countries to stop departures and
we hope that Brussels is finally
starting to understand thanks to the
Italian government we hope so and so
we're going to work hard for a
center-right majority to finally shake
off ideologies switch to Common Sense
and solve
um problems for European citizens rather
than creating them and Mattel so Vini is
on trial for defending European borders
blocking departures and reducing deaths
in the Mediterranean the league is
continuing this battle to save lives and
guarantee safety fighting against the
business of traffickers that's always
been our priority and it continues to be
so thank you very much on behalf of the
left group and the European Parliament
Mrs Aaron
well
since rescue isn't a priority in EU
we've got
10 people dying every day in the
Mediterranean every 10 days you have a
vessel
um
accident involving wrestling with deaths
27 633 people have lost their lives
women with infants minors
look madam a commissioner crocodilectors
are not going to actually
solve the problem we need action we need
uh infringement preceding since Greece
and its Coast Guard which is driving
people to their deaths we need
consequences for Poland and Lithuania
that have legalized pushbacks we need
clear language directed at Maloney that
is standing in the way of a rescue at
Sea and criminalizing it commission and
Council prefer to trust the leban Coast
Guard the so-called Coast Guard of Libya
which just throws people into jail and
systematically subject women to rape
rather than a trust an NGO that saves
lives on a daily basis that's the fact
we need instead of setting up a European
Maritime Rescue Mission you simply do
nothing along with far-right populate uh
who prefer to drive people to their
debts we must see Return of the rule of
law and the lives of every individual
human being must be protected
bricks may I also remind you that we
have to finish on time we have important
votes ahead of us so I would like to
kindly ask you to respect the time that
is allocated to your intervention so we
follow with colleague Mr Papadakis to
floresios
and can I ask colleagues to take to to
take the seats thank you
I'm sorry we continue with the debate on
the floor I'm sorry I would please
respect the rules of December and I
asked Mr Papa that kiss please
the Greek government and from Texas
still not come up with answers about the
criminal shipwreck of pilos with
hundreds of victims on a boat that have
been under surveillance for at least 16
hours without the alarm being raised in
a search and rescue area of Greece this
is an ongoing crime with the signature
of the EU and Greek government it's a
policy of repression deportations
repatriations
um there's
unanimity
in the Council on further repression
displacement of people deferred
countries and the bargaining with
compensations of 20 000 per head
and this disagreement on the sharing of
repression and competition and when to
open the gates to cheap labor
investigation and Truth is what we need
here about the criminal shipwreck in
pilos we need to strengthen the common
struggle of peoples and refugees against
unacceptable decisions of EU governments
that ignore the Geneva Convention Asylum
committees in Turkey under the
responsibility of the UN and the EU to
take applicants to their final
destination countries
dear president president commissioner
fundamental
values of human European democracy
require that we must help those who
require help and assistance that is the
basic principle of human dignity
but placing human dignity at the very
top of our policies and migration policy
doesn't mean that we just have political
attacks at the aftermath of a true
tragedy it's not enough for the
situation to be visible
in the Mediterranean Sea what we're
seeing there is more than just calling
out disasters we need a strategy that
will truly prevent and avoid these
events from taking place we need
more support to Frontline countries
which are saving lives on a daily basis
Operational Support so to make sure that
search and rescue missions can be
efficient together with
frontex we need to break down
trafficking networks which are take
advantage of human weaknesses and
vulnerabilities we need to break down
and dismantle these networks and inform
people about the true risks that they
are taking
we need to go further we need to
guarantee that when it comes to Asylum
claims they are processed in due time
and that those who do have a right to
stay are welcomed and integrated so that
in spite of the safety relative safety
they are living into conditions that are
incompatible with the principles of
human dignity thank you that's your next
speaker colleague
foreign
thank you president and thank you to
commissioner Johansson
for taking part in this important debate
the
tragedy of the Adriana in pilos I think
unfortunately has been The Chronic The
Chronicle of a Death announced and I
think that there are serious political
and criminal responsibilities that need
to be addressed in this case but first
and foremost what we have to
get from this debate in this resolution
is that what happened in pilos never
happens again in the Mediterranean and
for that I would like to thank my
colleagues from other groups Lucas
Mandel from the Epp Fabian Keller from
renew
Eric Marquardt as well from the greens
and Cornelia ends from the left
for having
come up with the proposal we're making
in the resolution to be voted on
tomorrow to have a European search and
rescue mission because what's clear
besides the ideological issue
on this question is that there is also a
matter of European responsibility and
subsidiarity there is a humanitarian
obligation to save lives at Sea an
obligation that shouldn't separate us in
this chamber neither by ideology nor by
subsidiarity so let's move in that
direction let's all unanimously vote
together on this resolution to send out
a clear signal to the council about what
we are calling for from this chamber two
days ago the headless body headless
headless body of a two-year-old boy was
found on a beach in Tarragona in Spain
and the police think that he drowned
trying to cross the Mediterranean let's
not allow that to happen once again
[Applause]
I'm sorry Mr Jones
I will speak Polish
please take your hands
up
I have a short question because you
suggested something a solution so
establishing a European Mission uh
European Rescue Mission but right now
the question is how would that be
financed in a situation
where where in the multi-annual
financial framework we are already
missing money and commissioner Khan is
suggesting that members State states are
the 65 billion euros to the budget
so where would we find the money for
your idea thank you very much
thank you very much the colleague for
the question
we are proposing a European mechanism
that will include member states and
frontex so a joint mission that will
ensure that we have the best possible
coordination and
cooperation
the mission
may require some funding
as you have pointed out and we will try
to find Solutions in the resolution and
in the mff multi-annual financial
framework
let's not forget that the member states
themselves have the vessels that will be
required in order to roll out the
mission muchas gracias next speaker
colleague Mr azmani please
well uh foreign
thank you very much Madam chair I'm
going to be
three weeks ago I was in lampedusa and I
saw with my own eyes
and how many migrant boats are now
arriving in Italy
this cynical model of human smuggling
makes life even more dangerous many
Crossings are now take being undertaken
it's self-manufactured metal boats that
capsize easily and they pose a risk a
hazard to the rescue crew and the result
attract tragically High number of
drowning victims and an unsustainable
influx of Asylum Seekers towards Italy
towards Europe
and this can't continue
it can't just be helped by more search
and rescue or for example on the right
you hear that yes we need more border
fences but that's not enough
because you can have this rhetoric but
that won't prevent people from dying in
the Mediterranean if you really want to
prevent this you have to have agreements
with the countries from which these
people arrive and these people who are
leaving these countries and that's why I
ask the commission to now put this at
the highest political level to negotiate
with Tunisia use all the resources we
have to avoid that these dangerous
Journeys are even undertaken that's the
only way we can have a hewn migration
policy this is strictly
the president Council commissioner
the pillar shipwreck proved again how
little value the lives of migrants and
refugees hold according to our member
states
and let's admit that the approach on
search and rescue just like the funding
of the criminal and smuggling Libyan
Coast Guard is about deterrence of
arrivals and not by the actual saving
lives
stopping impunity is the only way so
commission join our call for an
independent investigation
condemn Malta for letting people drown
under their watch
and Greece in Italy for obstructing and
punishing the life-saving work of ngos
give your guidelines against
criminalization of humanitarian Aid a
true meaning
The Pact on Asylum migration doesn't cut
this crisis we need a pact on search and
rescue one that centers on solidarity
among all member states on
accountability on a uniform application
of maritime law and enhanced funding and
support for saving lives at Sea it is
the moral and legal duty of the EU to
ensure a genuine coordinated response
now thank you thank you very much
[Applause]
foreign
no
I've heard this a number of times
of today the illusion of the left
populists this business model of the
fighting the Smugglers
so right now we have high risk and low
profit that would be the new policy
let's look at the past policies and how
well that functioned
so the higher the risk the higher the
price and the higher the profits
and so of course I'm in favor of search
and rescue missions but that doesn't
automatically mean
that these we should be allowing these
trips towards Europe and we should
support them rather we should negotiate
and work together with the countries of
origin and and and have return of
someone who has arrived illegally to
Europe or who has not carried out an
asylum procedure if you if you reward
these people with Asylum procedures then
people were going to continue to come to
Europe and die on the Mediterranean very
much next speaker Mr Madison the
floresios
thanks so much uh to your colleagues Mrs
Johansson first of all we have heard
several times how we are very sorry for
the victims in June when there was a
shipwreck uh on the Manchurian sea and
of course we are sorry for the human
lives there is no doubt about that but
we have to be also very very clear that
if you go to the sea with a very weak
boat then there's a very high risk that
you will die that's what will happen I
just have a question uh in June 8 if I
remember right four very small kids were
stabbed in the same country where we are
just now in France two of them were
two-year-old French kids there was a
three-year-old British girl and there
was a 22 month old
small baby who were stabbed by the
migrant from Syria and of course this
guy from Syria could be like in Europe
only thanks for your migration policy
have you ever contacted with those
families
who are worrying about their kids and
they were very very near to death
only because that we have an open border
policy and we're welcoming everyone as
Mrs Johan said we need them we need the
people from third world country we don't
know education we have no background
control
without any kind of control of their
like what they're gonna do here and we
need them I'm saying we don't need them
we don't need this kind of Commissioners
or european commission who doesn't care
about our own people can you that's the
fact thanks so much
uh colleagues I registered a blue card
but the speaker is on the speaking class
so you will have a possibility to speak
when it's when it's your turn so we
continue with the list of speakers Mr
arvanites the foreign
foreign
ladies and gentlemen we're talking about
a crime I think we'd all agree on that
whatever approach we take
a crime
um that we know will happen again
so
I'm sure that the majority here is upset
about this that we're
sad and of course we're going to hear
some people who are indifferent to the
tragedy
um
we are two worlds which are clashing the
world of humanity and that of inhumanity
now this situation what happened in
pilos was tragic and it requires us to
move forward despite our disagreements
uh
I'm not actually going to look at the
the causes I think we
need to take initiatives but Mr Weber
and the farmer right May um try very
hard but fences are not a deterrent
legal and safe routes to Asylum are ones
we agree with uh commissioner and you
must also help to convince governments
whose public statements devalue The
Proposal because that's a problem for us
Mrs Rosenberg she can maybe ask if she
would agree with the proposal so there
are questions for frontex that demand
answers to what happened in pilos how
was the departure of this death
actually allowed from ports in Egypt and
Libya did no one see that vessel
it was detected by the European services
and they were aware of the danger of the
situation so why were no orders given
for the immediate evacuation of the
vessel and the rescue of the people
who's responsible for this why were
there no life jackets who is responsible
president
colleagues European citizens oh let's be
honest the Dublin agreement represents a
total failure it imposes on countries of
first entry that they Alone face up to
the epical phenomenon affecting the
whole of Europe and that's shameful in
Italy in Greece thousands of migrate
migrants are arriving every day and for
search and rescue seaweed means people
and funding from All European countries
because these people come to Europe not
to Italy
the Italian state
has looked to look at this and the
European allies from the right have
refused that agreement so we're seeing
these tragedies at Sea as in coutro as
in pilos thousands of children women and
men who die at sea in the indifference
of so many people who seem incredibly
um to be aware of all of this so let's
get rid of Dublin as thunderline
promised let's share the
responsibilities for search and rescue
at Sea so that we delete once and for
all the shame of a Mediterranean which
has been transformed into a huge
Maritime Cemetery of totally Guiltless
citizens and human beings
foreign
thank you president
well we can't accept that when there is
a debate on migration and serious issues
about respect for human lies there is
always an attack condemnation from
people who live in member states where
they never see anybody arriving they
have no idea what it means to go and
save lives at sea so they have to attack
Italy and Greece if Italy wasn't there
there would be a hundred percent people
dead at Sea and this document this
resolution serves nothing they're just
words because the only true thing is
that they should not go to see because
they will die they will die because
there are these vessels because as soon
as they see a vessel whether it's in the
NGO whether it's a coast guard they all
throw themselves to one side it capsizes
and they fall into the sea and they
can't swim so this document is there for
the ngos written by various people we
the Italians have brought in a law which
once again imposes checks on
disembarkations in safe ports but the
ngos want to go where they choose so
once again in this resolution we are
talking about the nearest Port there is
nothing these has to be the ports this
cited on by member states where there
will be the necessary assistance food
medical assistance available for these
people
so I think it's completely out of place
commissioner you were in lampedusa so
thank you thank you first and foremost
the the Italian Coast Guard is saving
um saving lives at Sea 24 hours a day
the
um Malino and the deputy mayor these
people have to be thanked
thanked
president
and you're you're letting people from
the left speak about this I'm sorry it's
not right there's a debate going on I'm
sorry Mrs mussolina your times expired
will you accept a blue card will you
accept a blue card
Mrs Mussolini value except a blue card
blue card
okay so uh Mrs Miranda please the floor
is yours
listen
when you're sitting there in the back
benches you get all worked up and you
don't start shouting making a fuss and
banging on the tables it's a lack of
respect for this house to be clear well
here on the left we're here to defend
values human rights defend migrants and
people
I've been to Italy I've been to
uh spoken to the previous government and
the current government and the
vessels that weren't being rescued so
you can't give any us lessons on
Democracy we were can you tell us
whether that vessel actually got out uh
under Italian law the law was saying
it's not exactly a law that's in line
with European criteria
well let me say exactly this we want
rules ngos cannot themselves select the
ports because those ports have to have
the necessary systems for migrants so
you can't decide from your seat
nor can the NGO it's the member state
that have to decide this who are
responsible for helping
um migrants that's the law and law has
to be respected
thank you next speaker colleague Mr
Bartolo floresios
ity
thank you president
well let's make one thing clear
people are not lost at sea
um when there's a shipwreck like that
people die the numbers provided by the
international organizations talking
about people who've disappeared and
numbers of people who have died that
every now and again they see washes up
bodies and Alessandra of those bodies I
have received many and I'm not ashamed
to be from the left it's been 30 years I
have been helping these people and in no
way am I ashamed this resolution we're
talking now about a resolution because
that's what we're here to debate tries
to avoid that these numbers increase
again it wants to avoid other tragedies
like lampedusa coutro pilos and stop
other people leaving
this resolution cause on the EU to
protect people's lives without
um
sending them to third countries that
don't respect human lives or without
realizing ngos it calls on Europe to be
itself
to avoid uh ship reps that's what it's
about it puts each and every one of us
in the face of our own responsibilities
and anyone voting against or abstaining
well it will be up there consciences to
respond for them thank you Mr donkey
please
president
thank you president
minister of State commissioner
some principles are established in
international treaties and underlie a
very civilization saving lives at Sea is
one of those and that principle is above
every other assessment of migratory
policies or any presumed National
interest yes we need to invest in
cooperation with countries of origin yes
we need to step up in combating
Smugglers but
only if we have safe and secure
migration channels where we have a valid
alternative to these boats on which many
people risk their lives president I
would also like to stress how
contradictory the assessment of many
European leaders is including the
Italian Prime Minister who see the
Panacea in protection of external
borders when there is no land but the
sea protecting borders means abandoning
men women and children off our coasts
and from that to the rescue missions
even in line with the laws Etc it's a
small step a stop a step which will go
undermine the entire progress made by
our civilization
excuse me thank you president
for each disaster a debate and ever more
shame the European Union is now
surrounded by a maritime Cemetery we're
seeing the mafia of Libya being funded
and in 2023 shows very clearly what the
consequences are in terms of the deaths
um 22nd January humanitarian action
stopped 26th of February calabrian
deaths and 25th of March ocean Vikings
fired a 27th of April commissioner
Johansson asks Tunisia to guard our
borders for 150 million 24th of May 500
people in stress in Maltese water sent
to Libya 2nd of June June
humanitarian vessels stopped in the
reaction 8th of June those solidarity
mechanism is stopped for such a security
14th of June more than 600 people will
die in Greece 21st second the 24th of
June
um
for uh drownings in Italy Spain and
Tunisia 7th of July
um more firing at Ocean Viking on the
12th of July in Strasbourg we're seeing
um more
um we're asking for an end to these
killings
yes
thank you president commissioner in the
past three months we've seen four
hundred and forty one deaths and let's
not talk about the numbers for the year
before that it's a tragedy and who's
behind this the mafias that are
cooperating within Africa and secondly
political leaders who are not
um
and the ngos that are acting as
complexes in in this and the Poll for
massive migration the only solution to
really stop these buffers is to really
fight them they say uh give me a few
thousand Euros there's going to be
someone who's going to
um pay for your flat schooling and
everything free of charge when you
arrive we say to these people uh don't
pay a cent don't pay one Euro because
the only answer will thing that will
happen is that you'll send back to your
country let's stop this sham
um
now we need to send
um set up centers for the analysis many
of these countries are receiving
thousands and millions
um we've seen trouble in France with
public order
and so let us not fool ourselves let's
focus on what matters fighting crime
the ass next speaker colleague
the floor is yours
colleagues
the right to silence being misused as a
migration Channel millions are coming to
Europe illegally and once they arrive
then they all have the right to enjoy
all kinds of social advantages without
making a contribution and that
that's why they are willing to risk the
dangerous journey and we and that is the
model of the Smugglers and because
they're depending on our naivete and and
our laziness and the fact that we're not
going to defend our external borders we
need a different policy we have to stop
oh with the policy of the open external
border and we have to the policy of
anyone
it comes illegally is sent back and only
in that fashion can we undermine the
business model of the human Smugglers we
have to do as
Australia we have to have a return
policy rather than a welcome policy we
have not we have to have a pushback
policy that's the only Humane response
thank you next speaker accordions
it's not just a tragedy it's a crime
that's been committed
when the Greek Coast Guard did not
assist the ship that sank with hundreds
of people
who died
and instead of trying to prevent frontex
and the EU and the nation the the
national Coast Guard made themselves
guilty of contributing to the death
and
and countries are continuing their
pushbox and the death continues
this is racist it's inhumane and it's
illegal
those countries who are doing the
the countries who are doing pushbacks
and they don't you you have to have the
rescue operations you can't criminalize
ngos who are rescuing people you have to
create safe channels of migration this
is all possible we just need the
political courage to do so thank you
very much
8.4 million migrants have asked asylum
in the European Union since 2001. that's
the size of Austria and they will
continue to arrive by the million for as
long as you continue to welcome them and
spread them across Europe and it's your
fault if a few die and at Sea because of
your laxist pews your humanitarianism
and you want to organize their welcome
set up taxi services and play the game
of mafias and traffickers who are
driving this illegal trade these are not
refugees they're not uh fleeing
persecution of War they are coming to
take benefits our generosity and
bringing
poverty crime quite often and off
sometimes even terrorism we have to make
a choice either you're moralizing or our
way of life
and
we've seen the riots in France we've
seen of what's happened in terms of the
safety of our children
you have your policy I have made my
choice and history will be the judge of
these decisions
thank you madam president
colleagues once again we are discussing
the borders
that's where we need a European holistic
approach commissioner we think it's
unacceptable that you're pointing the
finger of a country of First Acceptance
without looking at the data condemning
Greece and saying it's responsible for
the lack of human lives with no
testimony or the data do you want to
hear the data men and women in the
Hellenic Coast Guard are heroes
colleagues Heroes only over the last
four years
2019-2023 they've saved 40 000 human
beings in the sea from about 1 300 cases
and
270 traffickers have been arrested from
various different organizations that's a
role of Greece and every single one of
us no one can claim that there are more
humanistic than others we all are but
there's a problem we have to find a
solution how can we find a solution if
we can't decide that as you yourself
said commissioner that there the main
problem is that the traffickers
themselves that they are using these
desperate people and people who can't
save themselves but we need a very clear
search and rescue mission together in
cooperation with frontex and in line
with international law because otherwise
everyone with a different voice who
speaks out against the countries of
First Acceptance I'm sorry you are not
helping solve this problem thank you
very much next speaker please
the joint resolution as tabled by five
political groups it's a very
um comprehensive one and I hope it shows
the real risks of crossing the
Mediterranean and the consequences of
taking this deadly route and I hope it's
not just a tactic within certain groups
to try and
text that calls for European rescue
missions the mission is something that
we've been asking for year for years now
and we've heard
we have strong arguments back this and
that's why I call on the European
commission to take its responsibility
and the argument to say that only
National competence is at stake it will
not resolve the problem we need this
Mission but we must go even further
because 27 000 people have lost their
lives since 2014 on this deadly route we
cannot lose any more time thank you
next speaker please
yes thank you madam chair Madam
commissioner Mr Minister let's compare
here
the billionaire on board the Shipwrecked
Titan was a Pakistani Citizen and holder
of a Maltese Golden Passport
209 Pakistani people on board the
Adriana had no Golden Passport indeed no
legal pathways
yes people smuggling is a Despicable
crime that must be fought but don't try
and distract and shift the blame because
once a boat is out on the sea and in
trouble as the commissioner said our
first duty is to save lives full stop
there are no butts I hear people say
here yes we have to save lives but
there's no but we save lives now in the
case of the pillow shipwreck
in the case of the pillow shipwreck
they're very strong indications that 600
deaths might have been prevented an
independent International investigation
is essential to make sure there is no
cover-up
finally we urgently need a common EU
search and rescue capacity without
further delay or excuses and as the
commissioner said very very well let our
action be the monument to the victims of
pilos thank you commissioner
[Applause]
thank you very much next speaker
colleague Mr bozellage the floor is
yours thank you chair colleagues I just
want to go back to what actually
happened which is that almost 600 people
died and I think we hear a lot of you
know talking about Asylum about
smuggling and so on but we should really
picture what that means I mean here
there are around 700 people if the room
is full that would mean that almost like
600 of them would would die I think it's
important to picture that this is a
couple of moments of people actually
drowning in the bottom of a boat
and then we talk about search and rescue
and I ask myself like why do we actually
call it search and rescue I mean Eric
you described it quite well they were
first ignored in this boat
and then they were not rescued but they
were towed away and which is why the
boat very likely capsized so we
shouldn't call the search and rescue we
should call this something like ignore
and risk their lives
so Costas you said that's a crime yes
it's it's a crime and the crime is not
that we're not following up with
Smugglers the crime is not that we're
not doing enough to save these knives
that we are stopping ngos from going
there and yes that is an Italian problem
as well as it is a Greek problem so I
really believe we need the EU that state
um
are you such a rescue mission we need to
monitor what happened and we shouldn't
forget the lives of these people that
are lost thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
today's debate
talks about a need to go and find
migrants at sea
on the eve of
the migration practice shows the
blindness of amongst this Parliament
with regard to the situation
when vessels are a distressed there's
not an obligation to go and rescue them
I'll take them to Europe for that matter
because there are
we know that ngos are connecting illegal
migrant vessels and bringing them to
Europe This is the policy pursued by
those who want to promote migration
because of their political ideology and
who want to Europe to become a welcome
center for migrants and
um
let me say that Patriots in Europe are
standing up against it and don't want to
be wiped out and at the next election
the European election they will hold you
to account
you say that we need to beef up our safe
search and rescue missions because of
the many tragedies with migrants but the
fact that illegal migration is a tragedy
in Europe well you're shutting your eyes
to that
let me say to you
that
here in Europe what we need is law
enforcement and Military on our borders
to ensure that migrants stop coming to
Europe
so why is it that just anyone can cross
borders
who are amongst you will just leave your
front door open uh when you leave your
house would you would you sleep soundly
with your door open wide open no
you have to stop these gangs you have to
stop the traffickers and the taxi
services that are being organized form
illegal migrants otherwise we'll just
find ourselves in the same situation
that we're seeing in French cities that
are burning
thank you to president colleagues
tragic scenes from the Mediterranean
that we have been witnessing reminders
once again that by not having a complete
system when it comes to migration and
Asylum Europe in a great part is the
victim of the will of traffickers who
are gambling with the lives of people a
recent visit to lampedusa from
colleagues with from the committee of
civil liberties has shown that this
island is a symbol of the dysfunctional
policy of migration of the European
Union if we want to avoid further
tragedy and further migrational pressure
that is um
occurring for Europe and this island we
have to be brave without emotional
blackmailing and Europe definitely has a
duty of solidarity toward those who are
in danger but we cannot indirectly
support different organized networks of
traffickers who are making profits by
selling very dangerous and
lethal arrangements for coming to Europe
we have to support frontex with their
challenges and we have to support the
member states that are under the highest
pressure we need a European agreement on
the system of migration and Asylum thank
you the wrestler next speaker
and I would like to announce that we
will now close the list of dkhdi thank
you
deployed Millions spent all news
channels stopped the regular
broadcasting and focused on the search
and rescue of five very rich people who
went missing in a submarine
to have a look at the Titanic it was
good that everyone did their utmost to
try and bring them to safety
but let us not forget that there are
countless others people feeling
persecution yes and even hunger who
deserve the same level of urgency and
compassion every life is precious and we
must extend the same efforts and do
everything possible to rescue everyone
at Sea yes European challenges require
European Solutions yet we cannot have
European Solutions without European
solidarity among member states and this
can only happen and work with real
mandatory relocation only then can we
ensure that no one is Left Behind that
every life regardless of their money
regardless of their circumstances is
afforded the dignity and protection that
it deserves thank you
thank you very much next speaker
thank you very much president
the Shipwreck
it's that took place off the coast of
pilos calls upon all of us to think
carefully
we need to ensure that the European
Union provides protection for refugees
and migrants and we also have to look at
the responsibility of political parties
which instrumentalize the situation
in Greece the prime minister
has drawn his own conclusions no
responsibility can be attributed
to the Greek Coast Guard
he even talked about the bad intentions
of people who have a negative approach
well
we have to note the issues that there
have been with uh
telephone uh listening in and the
problems faced by my colleague Mr Andrew
larkis we need an independent inquiry
which
I can predict will not be accepted by
the Greek authorities the level of
hypocrisy of those in power
as uh similar to the sort of thing
the
we saw to the attitude of the brexiters
towards migrants in the UK trying to
draw profit from a a problem that
they're supposed to be resolving
do you think that brother sisters
parents children's would board a vessel
to cross the Mediterranean the thinking
everything will be fine that they're not
afraid and don't think that our Dane
won't be dangerous that they're Guided
by the hope of finding a better life
here than the one they're left behind
let's think about the people in the
Mediterranean and the Atlantic and the
channel
uh
building walls are also political
choices Harmony broken families and lost
lives do we have to count
press conference covering
how much hypocrisy do we have to
tolerate
we can put an end to these deaths as
politicians to make sure that we can
have a constructive management of
migration to have a safe legal ways of
Entry to decide that solidarity
reception Humanity dignity are our
common values to see decide today to
have a European safe
uh search and rescue mission and save
people
our civilization will be judged by these
acts
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
first of all I'd like to speak as a
representative of of a political group
that is against migration so demonized
by you every
every human has the right to be saved
but the issue is the political
discussion that we're having our
approach is different
often we talk about the
about whether migrants are being taken
towards Europe 500 kilometers or whether
they are taking a few Commodities back
towards North Africa and this is the
discussion that we have to have
and since 2015 we have
seen millions of people coming to Europe
this is a huge number of people bigger
than the population of Ireland and in my
view if we look at what's happening in
France
we can only have one we have to do one
thing we need to help people in their
regions we need to ensure people are
helped on the ground so they do not and
we do not need to bring all of these
people to Europe this is the right way
so that we do not need to deal with this
debate any longer thank you
next
[Music]
next thank you madam President we still
have no final uh death toll from the
disaster of the fishing boats that sank
off the coast of Greece last month
every single loss of life is a tragedy
and of course we must demand that member
states carry out rescue efforts in their
own Waters
but this is only a solution for the
symptoms of a non-functioning migration
policy
part of the long-term solution is to
crush the criminal human networks at the
roots roots that for instance go to
Middle East and North Africa this
requires cooperation with third
countries by requiring these countries
to put trafficking networks in prison
and to increase their control at the
Border in order to stop migrants this
should be a prerequisite to receive any
financial aid from EU or Our member
states
we must also remove the pull factors
that cause large number of economic
migrants to travel to Europe screening
processes are needed at the external
border and we need credible system that
enables those that has no need for
Asylum to return
thank you
thank you very much next speaker
colleague senior Moreno Sanchez
president thank you very much president
commissioner
state Secretary welcome to the European
Parliament
ladies and gentlemen gentlemen every
year we repeat this debate in this
Parliament and day after day the
tragedies are repeating are being
repeated in the Mediterranean if we look
at what's happened in the past 10 years
we have more than 600 people who
disappeared in the last shipwreck
and what we need to do is put an end to
these sea cemeteries
and
we've saved many lives in recent years
especially thanks to operations such as
Sofia and marinostrum but once again we
need to have human corridors and we also
need to change the Mandate of frontex
so they have the right funds adequate
funds
and in which member states and frontex
play their role to the max
this what's at stake here is human
dignity and people's lives but it's also
the Dignity of European institutions
and we are counting on the Spanish
presidency to move forward on this thank
you the next speaker Mr Andrews please
thank you madam president commissioner
and colleagues some of this debate has
been about the secondary consequences of
saving lives at sea that it will
encourage and somehow support the
business model of human trafficking
but certain things are so intrinsically
right like saving lives at Sea that
secondary consequences should be
disregarded
the consequences of not having eu-led
search and rescue is increased numbers
of deaths and torture in captivity in
detention centers in Libya these are
secondary consequences that we should
have regard to and this is why I
requested this resolution along with
colleagues in the snd the greens on the
left
the vote in 2019 is a stain on the
record of this house and I would like to
encourage all colleagues to do the right
thing and correct the record of this
house as long as we continue to allow
this senseless loss of life we cannot
claim to be a union of values thank you
thank you very much next speaker
colleagues
when cypriot
the cypriot
Republic
sent an SOS
the scale of the problem became evident
we
received 50 percent of refugees Landing
in Europe we're on the front line
and there are these flows in other
countries but for the size of our
country it's huge Cyprus is a stable
member state of the European Union with
the highest
deployment in terms of population
and what is the point of borders if they
can't be protected
if thousands or millions of illegal
refugees
come to our countries
refugees often come from Turkey they use
the proximity to our countries
and
they use the green line for to pursue
their political purposes it's essential
that we take a courageous approach to
this problem because the flow of
refugees is getting bigger
to protect the Democratic character of
our countries that speaker is
interrupted proceed with the next
speaker colleague
thank you next colleague Mr bielowsky
please
thank you for president thank you very
much president
one month ago almost 700 people drowned
off the coast of Greece and this is not
one sad case this is one of many and
many more will take place if we do not
take action
more than 27 000 people have lost their
lives on when fleeing Europe by the
Mediterranean what we need to do is end
something which we should have done long
ago and the first thing to do is vote in
favor of this resolution which
will put an end to these deaths we need
to have acknowledgment of C of rescue
operations
ngos are doing most of our political
work
people have the right to Asylum they
have the right to be put to flee hunger
and War and they need to do so in a
framework where we are not on the side
of the privilege privileged we need to
go in line with our commitments so that
it's not just an empty gesture we need
to have proper International solidarity
thank you very much your next speaker
colleague
Madam president
it's a in 2019 we had a debate in this
plenary which was absolutely identical
to today's it was absolutely identical
once again it was uh triggered by
another tragedy in the Mediterranean
since then 10 000 more lives have been
lost and the only question that we
should be asking ourselves here
colleagues is until when until when will
Rich developed countries come together
and commit to protecting human rights
will they continue to close their eyes
to this tragedy continue to fail to give
a satisfactory response to this
situation
how long will we go on without search
and rescue in the Mediterranean that is
properly coordinated between the
different countries and protects until
when are we going to continue to
criminalize ngos
which in many cases are the only
response that can provide search and
rescue in the Mediterranean because
there is a lack of presence on the
ground from the member states
colleagues we have to put an end to this
shame
because what we're talking about here it
brings shame upon all of us
thank you very much and colleagues let
me on behalf of all of us so warmly
welcome
a delegation of parliamentarians from
Japan
who are here for the 41st EU Japan
interparliamentary meeting
very well welcome
[Applause]
thank you very much next speaker vice
president peterno please
thank you very much Madam president
commissioner colleagues
the illusion that some governments have
that they can seal the boards of Europe
ultimately betray the founding values of
European integration
Europe must remain a safe harbor for all
who are escaping from war and violence
and abuse
with this spirit
with the same spirit that we received so
many Ukrainian refugees
that's the same spirit with which we
should look to the Mediterranean
if you look at Europe from Kiev it's not
different to looking at Europe from a
trawler in the middle of the
Mediterranean
both
look to ours as a safe harbor
so what can we do against the deaths at
sea the terrifying choices that the
right would like to take we would prefer
to work for a mission of search and
rescue at Sea a European Mara nostrum
that can ensure that saving lives comes
back to being the center of our
migratory policy thank you thank you
very much correct I have three speakers
on Mike HDI list and I'll start with
semester Lopez Aguilar por favor
thank you very much president and
Spanish presidency and commissioner
Johansson
in 2019 I had the honor of being a
reporter on a resolution from the
European Parliament which demanded a
search and rescue framework in Europe
and four years later we have seen
thousands more debts people who have
died in shipwrecks and tragedies not
only on the Mediterranean route but also
in the Atlantic right in on the route
towards the Canary Islands
European CN search and rescue would give
Coast Guards and member states would
help member states that would together
with frontex they could coordinate
search and rescue operations but it
would also help them to land at safe
ports and it would help identify and it
would give people protection once they
actually landed and this is why we need
that approach we need to have legal
Roots safe landing safe disembarkations
so
that the coast guards and member states
will not be abandoned because this has
become a terrible situation we're seeing
it four years later even after we
debated this in the European Parliament
then thank you gracias next speaker
the floresios
the 2019 vote in this Parliament is a
state on us all and I was complicit in
that stain because I was not present to
vote on that day
since then thousands of more people have
died in the Mediterranean how much
longer must we exempt ourselves from our
responsibilities to ensure that we have
the basics of search and rescue
available to people who are drowning in
the Mediterranean just because we fail
to deal with the human traffickers and
the camps in North Africa and elsewhere
and the flow of people across into
Europe just because we fail to deal with
that does not mean that we should fail
in a human being's hour of need when
they are gasping for air as they drown
in just off the beaches where we lie
sunbathing during the summer it is
shameful
and the European Union and this
Parliament must ensure that search and
rescue is at its best across the entire
Mediterranean to ensure that we control
a Life by to a human being who was
drowning as I say just yards from where
we lie in beaches during the summer
thank you very much last speaker on my
list Senor solai por favor
thank you very much president
yesterday something terrible happened
in the arroa beach in Catalonia
the body of a child h2o3 was found was
an advanced stage of decomposition and
the police are working on various
hypotheses one of them is that this is a
victim of a shipwreck
for a ship full of migrants
this is a very simple question not
emotional Black Moon
do we not have the means and Technical
means
and capacity to coordinate and save
lives and prevent these tragedies do we
not have the means to comply with
international law
the Mediterranean is one of is the most
lethal sea but it's not the biggest
nobody should be dying in the
Mediterranean we need to help the
countries of origin of course we need to
do that but once people are at Sea we
need to prevent tragedies we need to
save lives and we need to put all of our
political will into this and all
resources we have to do so we've had
enough of excuses yes thank you very
much colleagues and now I would like to
give the floor again to commissioner
Johansson for her comments and final
remarks
Madam commissioner the floor is yours
thank you very much Madam president
thank you all for this very important
debate
I think problems start when you no
longer think of people as human beings
the people in the Adriana and other
vessels are human beings they are men
women children
with hopes and dreams with families and
friends
many of you made this point today
the Adriana was wasn't the first
shipwreck
and we can't promise it will be the last
but we will never ever think that this
is acceptable
we must do what we can to prevent
further tragedies and I agree with many
of those you that make the strong call
for legal Pathways here today
it just doesn't make sense when we see
me member states and companies in need
of skilled labor and at the same time
people also desperate they put their
lives in a Smuggler's hand
they had had got to be a better way and
there is a better way we must provide
safe routes to Europe by building more
and better legal Pathways to the
European Union
and to prevent dangerous Journeys
it's necessary to fight the Smugglers
more effective
the Smugglers who do not see their
victims as human beings but as cargo a
source of profit the smartness of the
Adriana reportedly charged between four
and five thousand dollars each a total
of nearly 4 million dollars
Smugglers are organized criminals and we
must treat them as such
our first obligation is always to save
lives at sea
member State vessels private ships ngos
boats carry out this duty every day
and although a national competence the
EU must do everything in its power to
support search and rescue
frontex planes and ships support search
and rescue operation
and as executive director Hans Layton
told the Libya committee last week this
year alone from Texas helped to save 20
000 lives
and the commission is working with
member states to improve coordination
notably in the contact group on search
and rescue
we will continue
this work step it up and engage actively
with member states for them to take
necessary actions
because member steps should Step Up on
search and rescue it's their core
responsibility and they must take it we
will continue to support them to the
maximum of our capacity and ability
thank you again for this important
debate
[Applause]
thank you very much Madam commissioner
colleagues we are still continuing with
the debate and I have a pleasure to
invite to the floor Minister Navarro on
behalf of the Spanish presidency
por favor
thank you very much I'm Madam president
ladies and gentlemen commissioner
thank you very much for this debate
it's been a clear proof of how complex
migration issues are
and we have taken note of all of your
points and your comments
it's clear that in the Mediterranean
the situation in the Mediterranean needs
to be dealt with in a timely manner in
line with International maritime law as
I highlighted in my initial presentation
the presentation the presidency is
committed to an integrated approach to
migration continue to work on all of the
activities that I mentioned including
negotiations that are ongoing on
legislative Pro proposals on the
migration pact there'll be negotiations
in part in Council and between Council
and Parliament thank you Muchos Gracias
so the debate is closed we have received
three motions for Resolutions to wind up
this debate and the vote will be held
tomorrow
and the sitting is suspended for two
minutes we will resume at 12 with the
vote thank you
foreign